welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Hector Navaro and this is film
[Music]
ranks we recreate the definitive
authoritative top five ranking list that
will live on in infamy for an eternity
until the end of time today get ready
for a showdown of Epic Proportions in
this video we're diving head first into
the chaos the comedy and the sheer
unpredictability that is Deadpool as he
takes on some of the most formidable
foes the MCU has to offer that's right
folks it's time to explore the top five
Deadpool matchups we want to see in the
MCU we want to see some Carnage we want
to see some violence I'd love a [__]
oh God me too Wade Wilson The Merc with
a mouth has crashed the MCU party and
it's time to see who can keep up with
his razor sharp wit and Relentless
regenerative powers from multiversal
mischief to Cosmic clashes these battles
promise to be a wild ride so grab your
chimmy chongas sit back and let's break
down the most electrifying hilarious and
downright absurd showdowns that could be
waiting for Deadpool in the MCU get
ready for the Ultimate Clash of Heroes
and
anti-heroes you took everything from me
I don't even know who you are we had
guests Eric Voss and Brandon baric come
in to help us create this list after
locking ourselves in the breakroom the
three of us engaged in a profound
session of deliberation you can see that
we can
see you know that's great writing it's
even for the script that's too
good it was kind of like jury duty but
more fun we established guidelines for
these matchups and in our pursuit of
objectivity opened our minds to dissent
and try to eliminate any personal bias I
want to see a long take in a hallway
where Deadpool's arms just get severed
his head gets severed jez through this
meticulous and thoughtful process we
considered all options even seeking
input from our dedicated viewers through
a community poll all in our quest to
ultimately and definitively rank these
matchups if you love rankings like these
and want to see the live version where
we came up with this list head over to
our breakroom Channel where we release a
new episode every Monday now let's get
to it at number five what happens when
the MC with a mouth goes head to head
with the emotionless powerful and
enigmatic entity known as white Vision
my programming directive is to destroy
the vision it's a battle of brains Braun
and a whole lot of snark Deadpool with
his rapid healing factor and un Orthodox
combat style meets white Vision a
synthoid devoid of emotion making him
one of the most formidable beings in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but can
vision's logical thinking be a match for
Deadpool's erratic and unpredictable
nature regular Vision Scarlet Vision
he's got too much going on he knows too
much this this this child this infant
out there with with unlimited power uh I
think would be a great match up this
Clash is guaranteed to be a roller
coaster ride of chaos quips and perhaps
even a few existential questions would
Deadpool's Relentless humor break
through white vision's stoic exterior or
would vision's almost Limitless Powers
prove too much for Wade Wilson to handle
when Deadpool regenerates he's basically
the ship of Theus right be a experiment
that will break white Vision like this
for number four imagine the chaos that
ensues when the uncontainable Deadpool
crosses paths with the reality warping
enigmatic Scarlet Witch is that not
enough
no
this showdown promises a battle between
the unkillable and the Unstoppable after
seeing the Scarlet Witch Massacre the
Illuminati and Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness we would love to
see what kind of crazy ways Wanda would
try to kill Deadpool bisect him with his
own weapon turning him into human
spaghetti sealing his mouth shut for
Deadpool that's just a Monday it would
surely be a whirlwind of chaos and
hilarity as Deadpool collides headon
with Scarlet Witch's reality bending
might can Deadpool's unpredictability be
enough to outwit a being capable of
rewriting existence with a mere thought
in this face off the stakes are nothing
short of reality
itself one shot energy huh okay I'll try
it oh
[Applause]
yeah whoa what does one shot's Focus
chew
do
[Music]
eternity whoa one shot really is all you
need begin your transformation with
oneshot energy today by going to oneshot
energy.com new rockstars for 10% off
your order at number three we've got a
confrontation of cosmic proportions two
forces of nature Deadpool and Thanos
Collide in a battle that defies death
itself you should have gone for the
head when the MK with a mouth encounters
the Mad Titan expect a clash that pushes
the boundaries of absurdity and
immortality we're also going to take
away thanos's Infinity Gauntlet to keep
this a fair fight not to mention the
Josh Brolin of it all after his terrific
turn as Cable in Deadpool 2 how fun
would it be to see Brolin go up against
deadpol again this time as Thanos
Roland's dual role in the Marvel
Universe adds an extra layer of
delicious irony making this matchup not
just a battle of superpowers but a
playful nod to the behind the-scenes
magic that brings these beloved
characters to life just a quick friendly
reminder to like And subscribe to new
rock stars turn on those notifications
and please leave a comment below at
number two get ready for a spectacular
Faceoff that's been a long time favorite
among Marvel afficionados it's a battle
of the acrobatic and agile as Deadpool
crosses paths with the friendly
neighborhood webslinger Spider-Man you
hey could you hold this for a second
thanks hey is this anybody's bike in a
world of wits webs and onliners this
matchup promises to redefine the meaning
of a friendly fight as these two fan
favorite characters Collide the question
lingers can Spider-Man's moral compass
and Youthful exuberance stand up to
Deadpool's amoral Antics and snarky
cynicism and which Spider-Man could
Deadpool fight Tom Holland Andrew
Garfield Toby Maguire how about any of
them this is a matchup that's been
debated and wished for by fans for years
now it's time for honorable mentions
before we get to number one these are
some other matchups that didn't quite
make our top five first off we have
Deadpool versus Wolverine a matchup so
good it's already happening we're
looking forward to their Collision in
next year's Deadpool 3 hey it's me next
up we have Doctor Strange who's magical
abilities could not only be a formidable
threat for Deadpool but Benedict
Cumberbatch can also keep up with
Reynolds in the quip Department as well
you guys chart in the 60s and finally we
have the Battle Royale of red spandex
Deadpool versus Daredevil we would love
to see the gritty violent Netflix
version of Daredevil go at Deadpool in a
No Holds Barred fight what the heck
maybe they could even fight in a hallway
that would be good and now our number
one Deadpool matchup in the MCU this
pick is sure to stir up some controversy
but in the heart of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it's a showdown that blends
Brawn brains and plenty of banter the
irreverent MK with a mouth versus the
Jade giantes Deadpool versus She-Hulk a
showdown between Deadpool and She-Hulk
is a collision of characters who not
only possess incredible Powers but also
share the remarkable ability to break
the fourth wall
oh that sucks Deadpool's notorious
pension for breaking through the screen
and speaking directly to the audience
with his razor sharp wit is legendary
y'all caught up
[Music]
now pair that with She-Hulk a character
known for her own self-awareness and
you've got a dynamic duo that can blur
the lines between fiction and reality
like never before their shared ability
to acknowledge the absurdity of the
situations they find themselves in
creates a unique and hysterical
Dynamic you need to back off and waste
this outfit Eugene get out of here don't
you're making a mistake and that is our
top five Deadpool matchups in the MCU
this list as promised will live on in
infamy for an eternity until the end of
time as the definitive authoritative
list if you want to see how we came up
with these rankings check out the film
ranks discussion on our break room
Channel and don't forget to leave a
comment did we forget any matchups do
you feel our ranking should be in a
different order let us know and maybe
your matchup will make it into a future
video for now this has been this week's
film ranks I'm Naro signing off so I can
go heat up some chimy chongas in the
microwave
[Music]
bye